that's how you succeed in business you
should do the right thing it's how you
succeed in life you do the right thing
you know I'm gonna give up something
today I'm gonna live like no one else so
that later I can live and give like no
one
[Music]
here we are on the Sunday special with
our very special guest financial guru
Dave Ramsey super excited to have him on
but before we get to Dave Ramsey first
let's talk about your impending death so
the fact is that you're gonna plotz
sometime hopefully not soon and
hopefully much later but you should have
life insurance because life insurance is
one of those topics everybody knows a
little bit about but do you understand
it well enough to feel comfortable
buying it whether you're an insurance
expert or a newbie policy genius created
a website that makes it easy for you to
compare quotes get advice and get
covered policy genius is the easy way to
get life insurance in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers and
find the coverage you need at a price
you can afford from there just apply
online and the advisors of policy genius
will handle all the red tape for you
they'll even negotiate your rate with
the insurance company no fees no extra
fees no Commission sales agents just
helpful advice personalized service and
policy genius doesn't just do life
insurance if you're looking for
disability insurance to protect your
income or homeowners insurance our auto
insurance they can help you get covered
fast so no matter how much or how little
you know about life insurance you can
find the right policy in minutes that
policy genius.com policy genius is
indeed the easy way to compare and buy
life insurance be responsible adults
don't be buried in a pauper's grave make
sure that your family has money left
over if god forbid something should
happen to you go check them out at
policy genius.com again policy genius
the easy way to compare and buy life
insurance well Dave Ramsey thank you so
much for stopping by the program I
really appreciate it well I'm honored to
be here your legend it's honor to be
always well I mean right back at you my
family's been listening to you for a
long time I didn't know about it
apparently as it turns out over the
weekend I found on my in-laws listen to
you and my wife apparently listens to
you and I didn't know about it which
says something about both our marriage
and the success and I want to start by
asking you now what I want to get into
your financial strategies and kind of
your life strategies but what is your
background for people who don't know
your story and how you came to your kind
of realizations and program about
financial independence yeah well I
started out with all these letters and
licenses after my name is said I was
supposed to know something about money
and I started with nothing and we ended
up with about 4 million dollars or the
real estate by the time we were 26 and
back in the 80s I was making a couple
hundred a year which neighborhood I grew
up and we called that rich because it
starting from nothing and but I was
stupid I had borrowed too much money and
I spent the next two and a half years of
my life losing everything we owned
too much debt and I got a PhD in D UMB
we got a chance to star
/ with a brand-new baby and a toddler
and a marriage hanging on by a thread
and so kind of pierced through the
academics and through the lens of faith
and through the lens of common sense
found really common sense money stuff
and we started doing it ourselves and 30
years ago maybe you can explicate some
of the baby steps that you use because I
know so many people who have had serious
debt problems and have been attempting
to get out of those who have used the
steps that you talk about so what are
some of those those steps that you
talked about you know what we figured
out was that was that personal finance I
kept trying to fix it with the math cuz
I'm a math nerd and then I finally
figured out it wasn't a math problem it
was a me problem the guy in my mirror is
the problem if I can get that guy to
behave he can be skinny and rich but
he's got issues and so I figured out he
needs a clear path and basic financial
planning / mixed in with a little common
sense to make some gumbo we came up with
an idea that hey do this first then do
this then do this real clear and don't
deviate from it and lots of people did
it and it worked and we called it the
baby steps because you can do anything
if you just take a step at a time maybe
stepping once a thousand dollars quickly
save a little starter emergency fund to
is knock off all your debt except your
home using the debt snowball listing
them smallest to largest attack them in
that order three there's an emergency
fund go back to that thousand raise it
up to a fully funded grandma's rainy day
fund three to six months of expenses so
now you're sitting with 1520 thousand
bucks and no debt except your house now
you can breathe
that's a foundation and then you start
your investing into your retirement kids
college and pay off your house early
difficult millionaire pays off their
home in about ten point two years and
then you're set up for baby step seven
which is just build wealth and be
outrageously generous so I want to talk
about some of some of those ideas
because there's a lot there and as you
say a lot of that is psychological as
opposed to monetary so when I first
heard about your program and I've talked
a lot as I say a lot of people who have
used your program there are a couple
things that jumped out at me because I
too am kind of a math minded guy the
first one was when you talk about the
debt snowball you start with small to
large you list all the debts and you say
okay we've got a $200 debt pay that one
off first and you know build up to the
to the big debt and I'm sitting there
going okay well if you have a two
hundred dollar debt at two percent
interest and a ten thousand dollar debt
10% interest why not start with the one
with the high interest rates
mathematical blasphemy it really is for
a nerd like me it's like fingernails
down a chalkboard we're doing it wrong
you know we're doing it wrong but the
thing is if you go to the Y and you
sweat and you drink water and you don't
eat white bread and you gain weight you
will quit and the same thing getting out
of debt you need some quick
encouragement you need to go this might
work and then you pay off another one
you go well this might work you pay off
another one you like getting the
neighbor in here this might work hey
baby come over look at this we pay and
you start to get this thing happening
it's called hope and you actually
believe it's gonna happen and so and
what happens is the more people get
excited the the more they believe the
deeper they'll sacrifice and the faster
they get out and so this debt snowball
thing even though it's you know it's a
paradox even though that it works it
works and people don't get out of debt
using the other because they get stalled
out and I was just laughing we tell our
audiences you know if we were doing math
we wouldn't have credit card debt in the
first place it's not a math problem so I
want to ask also about who kind of your
target audience is because you know I
think that there are certain situations
right I'm I came from a middle-class
background by the time I was you know a
teenager a late teenager I'd say we were
sort of upper-middle class and I
incurred debt for college I incur debt
for Law School
you're very anti debt for college I
agree with you that many college debts
are worthless but for my wife for
example she's a doctor as people know
and she went to medical school and she
also went to pre-med for for undergrad
you know are there any situations in
which you think that taking out college
debt is worthwhile well I just don't
teach people to borrow money the
shortest path between where you are and
wealth is to stay in control of your
largest wealth building tool which is
your income now that puts some serious
hurdles in place when you're going to
law school or you're going you're gonna
go to med school but I talk to people
who go to med school and they find a way
they get scholarships they they do
fellowships the MD ph.d program there's
all kinds of ways to do it but it's
tough it's tough but so is paying off
250,000 freaking dollars and debt that's
tough too so
you're gonna pick you're tough you just
got to pick which one I mean and that
that's sort of I guess the question
because it sounds like there are certain
situations like the there are situations
in which if you have to have a
government-sponsored debt it seems to me
those are the situations in which it's a
bad idea to really take out debt if
you've got to take out a student loan
from the government in order to go major
in gender studies good shot you're never
gonna be able to pay that off but there
are certain professions where the the
income coming out is gonna be good
enough that there's a reason the bank is
giving you a low-interest loan if you're
if you're taking out a loan for pre-med
they're presumably giving that loan
hoping they're gonna get knowing or
having actuarial tables suggesting
they're gonna get paid back on the other
end so you know are you supposed to
forgo let's go federally insured loans
too and the inherent problem and it
becomes a policy problem when you get
right down to the core of it with one
point four trillion dollars now in
student loan debt
we're basically loaning eighteen year
olds who have never had a job and want
to get a degree in left handed puppetry
up to a hundred and forty five thousand
dollars I mean we the people are stupid
really stupid that we're guaranteeing
these loans I mean because there's no
guidelines on this whatsoever and the
parents many times don't care don't
bother to be involved or don't know how
to lead their kid you know they're like
malaria team they make their own
decisions that's probably not a good
idea you know maybe maybe we put your
arm around a little junior and say you
know we really do need to get a degree
in something other than you know polka
German polka history let's try something
else you know let's try to get something
actually it's marketable and that you
can put some tools in your belt to earn
a living so you live in my basement when
you're 32 let's have a plan here and
it's funny that you come at this from a
different angle from people like Peter
Thiel obviously you end up in exactly
the same place which is college is very
often a waste of time I maybe you ought
to just be going out and learning a
career apprentice in yourself actually
making something yourself I don't think
it's a waste of time at all I mean
higher education we just completed one
of our MC personalities Chris Hogan
we just completed the largest study on
millionaire has ever done we should say
ten thousand one hundred and sixty five
of them and the vast majority um have a
four-year degree they didn't do that
they didn't use that to get it though
that's what's odd 68% of them have a
four-year degree and almost none of them
went to prestige schools though look at
them with the state schools and
community colleges and that kind of a
thing and but you know it turns out
being
being educated is a good thing it's just
you know what are you studying and what
are your expectations but it just breaks
my heart when I get a young lady calling
me from Atlanta last week on my show and
she's got $165,000 in student loan debt
for a master's degree in sociology and
she makes $38,000 working for the state
of Georgia
where were her parents where we as a
culture failed her to tell her that was
going to work but then you can't throw
the baby out with the bathwater and say
well education isn't a good idea
but we're just stupid about education
that's the paradox so you know as far as
you know taking on Deb you know I'm
focusing around the debt because this is
one of the areas where as you say you
know like the kind of statistically
minded folks look at you and they're the
it sounds like blasphemy
so look talking about entrepreneurial
ism so when you look at the number of
businesses that are started in the
United States and that are successful
the percentage that were started off of
some sort of loan from family from
friends from a bank there there there
are a lot of businesses that were
started off at least with somebody
investing who was not the original
person where we're you know our business
for example we started off with an
investor and we went to the investor and
we had an obligation to pay off the
investor and our business doesn't exist
without us actually borrowing money and
then using it to build our business and
then paying back the investor and that's
true for an enormous number of publicly
traded companies you know is there a
happy medium here or do you really
believe that it's just a matter of
scrimping and saving until you can get
together enough money to start the
business because sometimes you actually
do need a spend of scale in order to
make sure that you can get launched well
if if you're an income I mean if you're
in game as an IPO if you're wanting to
go public you're probably dealing with
the vulture capitalists at that point I
mean you probably bencher capitalist
you're probably about to get yourself
into a situation where somebody owns
your soul and that's going to be part of
the process if you're doing something
like you guys are doing you've got an
angel investor that's that's setting you
up and believes in your cause and that
that gets you going in my case we
started on a card table in our living
room we've got eight hundred and six
employees today I will do about two
hundred million in revenue this year
we've never borrowed a dime but it
didn't take us 20 years you know 20
years later went overnight success yeah
it sounds like a pretty good plan I mean
20 years to 200 million dollars in
revenue ain't a bad thing so it worked
out so when it comes to kind of personal
character how much do you think that
financial decisions are about education
people to make the right decisions and
how much is it about actually being able
to put off what you want for what you
need now that's called maturity the
ability to delay pleasure and that is a
character quality integrity there's a
high correlation between integrity
wholeness not just telling the truth and
honesty but this full on integrity you
are who you are all the time that's
integrity and not only do you tell the
truth not only do you honor your word in
situations high data point correlation
between that and the ability to build
wealth
this idea that you cheat your way to the
top is mythology it truly does not work
out there I mean think about it if you
go to the local car place and get your
car worked on he cheats you you tell
everybody you know and you don't tell
everybody you know and if you go in
there and he says oh this was 35 cents I
fixed it don't worry about it
you tell everybody you know cuz you just
found a unicorn you know I mean so where
the guy just did the right thing and you
send your family your friends and that's
how you succeed in business you do the
right thing it's how you succeed in life
you do the right thing
integrity the ability to delay pleasure
the ability to say you know I'm gonna
give up something today I'm gonna live
like no one else so that later I can
live and give like no one else that's
why we say it on the show you know one
of the things that I think is so
fascinating about your approach is that
it is an approach that is driven by
personal responsibility so much of
what's going on in the country in
politics generally is driven by
precisely the opposite attitude so
you're smart you stay away from politics
I'm in politics full time and it seems
like politicians make Bank off of
basically telling people that nothing
they do is their own responsibility and
that everything that is wrong in their
life can be blamed on outside forces in
America how much of people how much of
what's bad in people's life do you think
can generally be blamed on the decisions
they make and how much can be blamed on
on outside forces if you had to balance
that out well I think you can be born
into a situation where you don't you
know you you're in I grew up in a
neighborhood where people said stuff
like the little man can't get ahead it
was a victim mentality blue-collar thing
it's like you know the the Union I'll
take care of you the government will
take care of you I sure hope we can
elect a you know a president or
congressman will take care of us because
the little man
can't get ahead on his own and and is
that a reality yeah if you think it is
if you think you can or you think you
can't you're right Henry Ford said you
know and so there's a reality to this
and so the belief is the real privilege
it's not the skin color and it's not
that a socio-economic thing it's the
belief in the culture you come out of I
mean I grew up in Tennessee and we're
hillbilly culture
my family's scotch-irish and proud
hillbillies of the best of the best kind
and an interesting Bunch they'll fight
you for their freedoms and yet sometimes
they'll adopt that victim mentality and
a whole bunch of those folks
I mean JD did a nice book hillbilly
ology that indicated that probably
that's a bunch of us are who elected
Trump but it was all that he was a
little bit Reaganesque in that it's up
to you I'll just make it where you can
win mm-hmm
you know and I'll do it for you and
there's a different message there in
that ideology but you know the problem
is if you start to believe someone else
is gonna fix your life whoever it is
your employer your mommy the president
the Congress you're screwed
yeah well this is one of the things I'm
really fear because I am seeing it rise
on both the left and the right there's a
sort of new right-wing populist movement
that suggests okay well you know all the
problems they're having life you didn't
get married because you couldn't afford
it and it's like well maybe you should
have made some different decisions and
single motherhood is not a financial
decision it's not that you got pregnant
out of wedlock because you couldn't
afford it okay the classic studies are
that 97 percent of the 30 year olds that
graduated from school high school before
they got married and got married before
they had a kid that's all they did
high school and they did in the right
order in other words 97% are above the
poverty level almost everyone below the
poverty level somehow got that out of
order I got pregnant before they got out
of school they got pregnant before she
married they got married before they got
it's good they got it out of order
it's the success order all kinds of data
points on that statistical evidence and
it's not a political statement it's just
this is the proper way to live your life
turns out morals have implication
characters character has implications so
in a second I do want to ask you about
what's happened because it feels like
there's been a decline in both happiness
and I've a tribute that to it
in a in virtue and religion I want to
see the kind of your perception that in
just one second first let's talk about
your healthcare program so I have some
good news if you missed the deadline to
sign up for healthcare insurance or more
importantly if you signed up for a plan
you're just not that happy with you
still have a choice it's called Medicare
Medicare is a Christian health care
sharing program they've been around for
25 years they've more than 400,000
members now around the country and get
this over the years Medicare members
have shared over two billion dollars of
each other's medical bills so they could
help share your needs as well best of
all you could save a lot of money with
Medicare the typical savings for our
families about five hundred bucks a
month your savings could be more they
could be less but think about what you
could do with that extra money every
month so if you think you're stuck with
a high cost health plan that doesn't
have much to offer think again you can
join bed a share anytime so just call
them today and check it out just head
over to Medicare comm slash Ben I'll
call eight four four sixty one Bible to
find out more there's no pressure they
are super easy to talk to you find out
how much you could save
why Medicare is really popular I've
talked to the folks over there really
nice folks Christian folks go to
Medicare comm slash Ben that's meed I
shared comm slash Ben or call eight four
four sixty one Bible for more
information again that's 844 61 Bible
844 sixty one Bible or Medicare comm /
Ben 844 61 Bible go check them out so I
want to talk about some of the the
aspects of virtue that you're talking
about because I fully agree with this I
think that the supposed crisis that
we're having in terms of happiness the
rise in the opioid epidemic above some
of that is due to bad diagnosis and
people being given medical opioids and
all of that
the reson suicide the rise in single
motherhood that in the end these are
mostly personal problems these are
people making bad decisions and they're
making bad decisions because they've
been taught by society by the government
by the culture that if you make a bad
decision it's not really your fault and
at the beginning of wisdom is
recognizing that it's probably your
fault where do you think these kind of
where did things start to fall apart or
do you think things are really not that
falling apart you know it's strange
there's pockets that are falling apart
and there's sometimes a malaise that are
fog over some things but then there's
entire segments of the population
they're booming like never before them
the best years of their life right now
and maybe did even under Obama you know
they the best years of their life and
but I mean we share a
book in our faiths and my Christian
faith through Jewish faith the prep book
of Proverbs a book of wisdom and all
throughout the Book of Wisdom the fool
is juxtaposed with the wise the wise
does this the fool does this wisdom is
this and wisdom is in the Hebrew you
know this probably is the art of living
life well is really what it means and
that's what we've lost his wisdom not
knowledge what we've lost wisdom as
juxtaposed with the fool and and if you
read through proverbs you go well I've
done that I'm a fool I've done that so
I'm look we're doing that someone be
watched in the house of the wise our
stores of choice food and oil but a
foolish man devours only has if you
spend everything you make you're a fool
fool fool fool I've done that and then
when I quit doing that actually save
money I had some money in the house of
the wise I mean it was just
it's remarkable in it and so the art of
living life well and and when you start
to believe that if I plant corn I'm
gonna get corn if I'm gonna reap what I
sow if I'm gonna live in a
cause-and-effect world where I actually
can impact my own destiny
there's variables around me there's isms
I mean there's racism and sexism and
bald ISM there are people that won't let
me do stuff cause I'm bald
hasn't been a bald president elected
since television go look that one up
it's interesting I mean you know these
kinds of things are variant we got one
with bad hair but we don't have any with
no hair you know I mean and so Jerry
Ford is not elected that there's always
you know I've got a southern drawl and
four years in the radio business now
we've got six hundred stations but for
years people in Boston thought we
broadcast from a double-wide because we
were in Tennessee you know with no
shoots you know I mean there's all these
isms right there's everybody's got an
ism they got a bus through I don't care
who you are but if you truly believe
because of your ISM whatever it is that
you can't win you're not gonna get corn
if you plant corn then why would you
ever plant corn that's hopelessness and
that's the the path of the fool yeah the
way that I've put it on my own show is
that I root for reality because there's
nothing else to root for but there's a
lot of folks out there who are rooting
against reality and you see this not
only in politics we see it in culture
just the general thing where people look
at their life and they go X or Y isn't
fair here's a person who's really rich
and I'm not really rich and that's
unfair and you see politicians say this
without any solution they just sort of
put it out there and this is their
actual talking point you say okay well
let's assume for a second that that is
unfair that if you were God you would
even all that out you're not god you're
not evening all that out and even if you
would even know that I wouldn't result
exactly in what you want here so maybe
you should stop fighting reality and
deal with reality instead you know
actually wealth equality is unfair
because effort is not equal smarts is
not equal I'm not as smart as Bill Gates
he's helped more people than I've helped
and as a result he has more money I mean
I haven't changed the world with a
computer he did I'm not Steve Jobs I
didn't do that now I've made a good bit
of money I've helped a whole bunch of
people but you know I was arguing with
this lady a liberal lady and she was mad
at me because I hadn't made a lot of
money selling books to people helping
them with money and she's like well
you're taking advantage of all these
people that are broke I said you know
when I when I sold five books for ten
dollars nobody was mad but all you
people got pissed off when I sold ten
million of them and I helped ten million
people and so the you know your your
level of return is the level of help and
so that that just defeats the wealth
equality argument completely because we
now know that 79 percent of the
millionaires in America today 8 out of
10 inherited 0 0 which means they did
something in the marketplace so the
American Dream is alive and well I mean
one of the things that I love that your
show is that you actually do defend the
morality of the free market and that
that's something that very few people
are willing to do in this day and age
it's all about the shortcomings of the
free market income inequality the idea
that people are being exploited and it
seems like they're coming from this
perspective that even basic elements of
life in the Intelligent gaps that this
should be somehow rectified and you see
this with they'll use Bill Gates is an
example how is there a Bill Gates in
this country who's worth this much money
and then you'll see somebody who's worth
no money and you know you say well he's
contributed more he's he's and they say
well but that wasn't his choice he was
smarter right he was smarter he grew up
better what how do you answer that you
know what he did you know he and he is
and you know George Clooney's prettier
than me so I mean so what deal with it I
mean you did this is your hand play your
hand and you know I was on a we had a
leadership event we did our entree
leadership event last
and I've spent some time with
Condoleezza Rice and she grew up in a in
a segregated neighborhood outside of
Birmingham and she's you know she was
talking about coming out of that
segregated neighborhood to become
Secretary of State she's brilliant and
brilliant lady and she said it my
parents told me my whole life it doesn't
matter where I'm coming from and what
matters where you're going
and you just decide that's what we're
gonna do but that has to all this all
the way back to the day with this thing
called hope and this belief that if I
plant corn I shouldn't be shocked if I
get corn if I plant nothing I can't
gripe about the farmer who planted corn
and was out there toiling to kill the
weeds and in the hot Sun meanwhile I'm
standing over here watching the guy and
then I go well it's not fair that he's
got some corn I mean I wonder if some of
the complaints that are cropping up
particularly among young people and I
speak a lot on college campuses where
there are a lot of young people who make
exactly these complaints that this is
coming as the result of a breakdown in
religious community because you know I'm
a religious person you're a religious
person there are a lot of rich people
people who have been you know I've been
a lot poorer I've been you know I've
done well that's changed but I've
watched the same thing happen to people
in my community who I grew up with and
so I know all of them and so it's hard
to be a lot it's a lot harder to be
jealous of the guy that you've known and
grown up with and he can go to for help
then some random guy on the streets we
have no association with and as we
fragment as a community there there's
more of a feeling of well maybe that guy
owes me money as opposed to well I've
known my next-door neighbor my entire
life we go to the same church or the
same synagogue the one area of equality
the matters more than any we are equal
which is we are all equal before God
right God sees us all exactly the same
with that breakdown I'm wondering maybe
that's what's caused a lot of the
feeling of dispossession well and it's
also you know contributes to racism also
contributes to arguments between
religions I mean if you sit down spend
time with people actually develop a
relationship with people that have
different situation than you've got
you're gonna learn there's good people
and there's bad people and almost every
one of those things
I know wealthy people all over the world
they're worth hundreds of millions of
dollars they're some of the best people
on the planet and I know some of them
that'll cut your throat just to see just
to see if you bleed I mean and I know
some poor people that are some of the
best people on the planet and I know
some of them cut your throat and
the money skepta with their character or
their lack of it the money just revealed
it so where do you think the country is
going are you hopeful or pessimistic for
the country you deal a lot with
individuals but on a broad level where
do you think the country is going right
now I mean my spoiler is that I'm always
pessimistic which is which is great for
me cuz it means I'm always right
eventually yeah just a question of where
the event happens but are you optimistic
or pessimistic about sort of the
direction that the American people seem
to be moving I'm optimistic overall
overall there's lots of issues there's
lots of problems and the I think the
biggest problems we've got are not
structural and they're not systemic the
the biggest problems are belief
breakdowns where people believe the
wrong things and when you believe the
wrong things then you make bad decisions
because your worldview is screwed and
that that's what breaks that's what
that's the most pessimistic piece of God
about it and so to the extent that we
can people like you can get out here and
be thought leaders and teach people that
they what happens in their house at the
end of the day is probably a lot more
important for the quality of life they
lead over the next several decades than
what happens in the White House so
what's your religious background where
do you come from like hum about your
parents because how did you get this
part of the question oh I didn't grow up
in church I grew up I was a hill racing
beer-drinking hillbilly I was a crazy
man no I met God as an adult and I
actually met him on the way up when I
was making that money and then we were
losing everything I got to know him on
the way down so I started studying
Scripture because I you know I had all
these letters and license after my name
and about money and then house it broke
something
I must have got some bad information
because I was acting on all the
information I had and it didn't take me
where it was supposed to take me instead
I built a house of cards that fell in on
me use OPM leverage other people's money
and all that stuff right and I got to
thinking about it and who was it taught
me to borrow money that was my finance
professor in college he was broke
kind of like a shop teacher with missing
fingers right that's a problem so I
started you know as a young person of
faith and young in my faith in my 30s
20s I really don't learn
what the scriptures say about money I
mean if you just read proverbs over and
over you have a master's degree in
finance so you have three kids and how
old are your kids
twenty-six
2:32 and and have they followed all of
your advice if they do yeah
okay and they're all actually
functioning human beings they have great
marriages married good people and have
great babies and great careers they work
very very hard they are not silver spoon
by any stretch one of the things that I
love about your show is that you really
do give tough love advice to a lot of
the folks who call it I mean it's what
makes it so entertaining is that you're
actually telling them the truth have you
ever felt bad after you get off a call
that you slap somebody a little bit too
hard upside the head um yeah oh sure
sure
but typically what I've learned to do in
the past more than in recent years I've
gotten better at it I mean because I can
judge what I used to do is I would just
hit everybody the same and that's not
fair if somebody joined our tribe three
weeks ago they've got a different set of
knowledge so I can't hold them to the
same level of account you know I started
I started watching your stuff on YouTube
Dave three weeks ago okay I'm on give
you we're gonna gently bring you along
but Dave I've listened to you for 10
years and I leased a car last week you
know I mean you're gonna get it you know
so because you know you know not to do
that I'll do everything you say to do
and then tell me three things you didn't
do you know so it's like I we're gonna
get you dude and it's tough love but you
know what that is that's real love look
I'm real love is always I mean I had my
son's 26 he's a wonderful fabulous young
man he's a vice president our company is
brilliant great entrepreneur when he was
eight he would not take a bath and his
dad made him bathe because you stink and
you can't exist in society if you don't
take a bath you know you don't brush
your teeth you're not gonna have any Sun
and I'm gonna make you do this against
your will for your own good I don't get
any benefit out of it at all it's for
your good best love like all the tough
love it's it's just being a good dad
this is one of the things that drives me
up a wall I know so many people who are
both adults and teenagers but it must
have been inculcated them in when they
were teenagers and now they carry it
forward this idea that you're 25 and
you've screwed up your life and if
somebody says anything that crosses you
it's because they don't love you enough
that if they truly loved you then they
would just accept you as you are and so
well maybe I'm trying to not accept you
as you are because you suck the way you
are maybe for stop suck
and then he will have earned the love I
think four duis is awesome just keep
drinking it's working for you yeah I
mean come on you're gonna spend your
life in a ditch if you live and don't
kill somebody else this is ridiculous
I'm gonna have to drag your butt out of
the bar boy I mean this isn't gonna work
for you and you just gotta love somebody
enough to go I'm not gonna participate
in your crazy I'm gonna stand over here
on the side and show you what sane looks
like come join us it's more fun over
here so what are your rules for
relationships you know a lot of folks
who are married or thinking about
getting married do you have any sort of
relationship rules and advice for folks
who are getting married that they should
keep kind of first and foremost in their
minds oh man I've been married 36 years
and happy wife happy life is the first
thing no I mean as far as the money
piece goes we have learned that when
people handle their money together
they're really setting their life goals
together they're sharing their fears the
sharing of stresses they're sharing
their dreams because their money all
runs towards those things way you handle
your money symptoms more of a symptom of
what's going on in your life than of
actual problem and so when we can get
couples to start talking it's amazing
they go through one of our classes and
they've been married 12 years they come
back you saved our marriage I'm like you
went the wrong class a sex class was
down the hall it was are we it was we
made them start talking about their
money one checking account shared
accounts we're gonna know everything
that's going on both of us there's no
I'm gonna take care of you you're not
you know you're not good with money
honey so I'll do the money no we're all
on this together one might be the nerd
that's gonna do more of the details but
we're gonna be two adults pulling the
wagon together and there's tons of data
that says you're not gonna build wealth
unless you do that so I I know again you
don't you don't get into politics too
much but from a general political view
I'm gonna ask you one political question
which is what do you think the proper
role of government is because it seems
like nowadays people think it's to fix
an income inequality guarantee people
jobs in your ideal world your King Dave
Ramsey do you get to decide you know
what government does and what government
does what do you think governments
actual role is well God has been smart
enough so far to not allow me to be
involved in that and I pretty much agree
with him so no I mean politically I'm
sitting here so I'm obviously
conservative
very conservative probably just to the
right of Genghis Khan but you know and
our my liberal friends my liberal
listeners they I make fun of them all
time on the air but but they know I love
them and I'll help them with their money
and I'll help them with their marriage
when they call in and help them retire
with dignity I'll show them how to do it
but I'm like people you know I'll help
you wherever you are that's okay but as
far as the reason I'm a conservative is
prop you know I was sitting with John
Stossel one night about 15 years ago
back when he did 2020 back a long time
ago and and he said I'm read up on you
and I said oh really that didn't take
long
because yeah you're a you're a social
conservative an economic libertarian wow
I never thought about that but I
probably am I probably am I'm a konami
libertarian because I'm a free-market I
mean I am a capitalist Pig
I love capitalism capitalism is what
happens if you leave people alone
you know they will go and function in
their own best interest some of them
will do it crooked some of them will do
it with morals some sanctified
capitalism some of them do it wrong and
you wish you hadn't let them run loose
just like when your children grow up
sometimes you wish you hadn't but that's
the way it is and but I see so much good
happen more good happen in the
marketplace when you let people do their
own thing I mean any time any time you
have put a large number of people in a
small area geographically there has to
be more rules we call that civilization
if you're going to be in the middle of
Montana and there's you know more sheep
per capita you know in this square mile
than people and there is it's beautiful
if there I love Montana and but you
don't need it I mean you can just walk
around the gun on your hip and you can
just shoot it if you want to you know
but if you do that right here in the
middle of La you'll not only go to jail
but you're in danger people what we call
that most of the city actually you know
but that's you know legally I mean you
know the point is more people you have
to have more rules and government is the
same way and so I love the old systems
of government I'm an old guy so you know
highways and and take care of the
military and a bunch of this other stuff
you know
they were just trying to engineer votes
and they should have be out at all of
those businesses so yeah if you made me
King there'd be a whole bunch of folks
unemployed that used to work for the
federal government very quickly because
I'd just do away with a bunch of it but
I'm not gonna be king so you're safe
it's okay all righty so I want to ask
you about charities so in your program
you talk a lot about how when you get
wealthy you should give a lot of charity
what do you think the role of charity is
because there's a whole group of folks
who are sort of the iron Randian
Objectivists you say that the best way
that economics works is to never give
charity the best thing you can do is
invest your money create more jobs why
do you think it's important for folks to
give charity well has nothing to do with
the economy as do what it does for you
god teaches both of our faiths to give
very very clearly tons of Scripture the
Talmud the Old Testament where we
Christians would call it and in the New
Testament as well tons so why would a
loving God suggest that you give money
there's nothing there the economics your
synagogue does not need your money
my church does not need money they're
gonna be fine I promise
so that's not what it's about this is
about what happens in me when I turn
loose of money and I see the result it
moves me from selfish selfish to
selfless it grows my character and
selfless people are highly attractive
much more so than selfish people and so
it turns out that the person who gives
is also the person who holds the door
for you and also the person has a level
of humility they understand the center
of the world really doesn't run through
the top of their head and so but there's
a spiritual result a character-based
result in a psychological result when
you go through the tactical step of
mathematically giving your money away
and so when you reach over and you see a
lady waiting a table and a greasy diner
and you leave her a $300 tip and she's
pregnant a lady needs some money
now you helped her but the economy was
affected but what it did for you was
more than any other player so oddly
enough charity is selfish in that regard
if you understand what it does for you
what it does for your kid
to see you give and and I've got a good
friend who's Orthodox Jewish rabbi rabbi
Daniel lapin and he cannot stand the
phrase and I agree with him give back he
says you're not giving back you didn't
take anything right you're just giving
you didn't give back indicates somehow
you took advantage of the culture and
you owe the culture a debt you know the
culture of that that's not true but you
owe yourself a debt to learn to have
that element of your character but
because people who give are always
grateful people they're more humble and
they're more selfless and they're highly
attractive people they're who you want
your kids to be they're who you want to
be when you grow up you know that's who
I want to be I meet those old men those
are women they got those beautiful faces
you know and then you meet the ones that
don't have beautiful faces says they're
angry and they're selfish and you come
it's up on their countenance when you
get old and because when you get old you
become more what you're gonna be right
you know and that's what charity does
now think about this though if we could
look at that on the macro level what
would happen Oh baby I mean what if we
could get a whole culture that started
giving not because of the economic
impacts not because they help this
little charity or not because this this
kid was fed although that's a wonderful
thing but we got a whole culture of
people who are highly attractive and so
flips instead of selfish and mean and
nasty and on Twitter unbelievable you
know ya know and I think that's exactly
right it's because I think that what
happens is that the folks who don't give
charity tend to be the folks who are
very eager to take somebody else's money
for somebody for something else
I mean it's there's a really high
crossover and not to get too political
again but they're this death show that
red states give a lot more charity than
blue states that religious people gotta
give a lot more charity than
non-religious people and those people
also tend to vote for small government
because again those people understand
that when it comes time when the pedal
hits the metal and it's time to help
somebody out that in the end it's up to
them it's not up to somebody else and
they're casting a lot a casting off on a
third party is a mistake and one of
things I always note on my show is that
when it comes to charity yes I have a
commandment to give charity but there's
no commandment to receive charity
there's no command we seem in our
society to have reversed it there's the
commandment is mostly that society owes
something to make it used to be that if
you took charity from somebody
you felt the obligation toward that
person because you knew who the person
was the person had a face and I always
say the movie Cinderella Man where James
Braddock is walking back into the
welfare office of the role of 20s and
paying back the welfare office what is
there a single person in the United
States who gets a check from the
government who would ever think about
doing that today probably not but if you
do it in the context of a community of
which are apart you know exactly how
much you owe to everybody else in your
community well and all that is is
gratitude if you've received it it
changes your gratitude level if you've
received help at some point in your life
you're grateful person and if we could
create a whole culture of people who
were self less rather than selfish and
in the process out you know we gave so
much into these institutions that you
may you could literally you literally
financially economically could make the
government irrelevant you could put them
out of business be wonderful so what do
you think you know as a person running a
massive massive business what have been
the biggest obstacles that you faced in
taking your business from non-existent
to a 200 million dollar business people
people our people on our team are our
greatest blessing and they're our
greatest pain we love them and they
drive us nuts sometimes people the human
the human resource and loving them well
compensating them well attracting the
talent and people with character people
that have quality that actually act like
they own the place and actually work
while they're at work and all that kind
of crap you know I mean it's that that
has been our biggest obstacle we are
tuner folks last year but but you have
to go through ten interviews with us
they were very hard to get on with but
we win best place to work every year why
be the best freakin place to work we
take care of our people I mean we're
we're very very good too but we require
a lot so you have to bring it baby we're
playing for the Super Bowl
dad said tell me about that experience
like how does that interview process
work that's a--that's a lot of vetting I
mean maybe we'll start doing that around
here well I mean I was so dumb when I
first started I thought if you hired
people they would just work you know and
I was dumb I mean I thought they would
actually care and I would steal and
turns out you have to hire people that
work and care and don't steal you can't
just hire people and they want to do you
have to actually vet that process
there's a due diligence involved so we
just found out if you spend more time
with people you get to know them
though they'll tell you we call them
thoroughbreds or donkeys you can't win
the Kentucky Derby with a donkey I've
never been one win it ever yeah and and
you can't win it business with a roomful
of donkeys and so sometimes a donkey can
dress up they put on their interview
clothes they look like a thoroughbred
when they come in but you have to talk
to them long enough until they finally
going yeah here yeah one someone's got a
drug issue I don't thing we're gonna do
that and that one's doing some crazy but
stuff in their personal life I don't
think we need that toxic stuff in here
and you know that kind of stuff
and so because you know everything moves
the speed of trust and if you can't
trust people's competence their
excellence their integrity their intent
then it's hard to work together you
can't get work done because you're
always looking over your shoulder Cena's
gonna stab you and so we just fire
people if they do stuff like that
have you started have you seen em you've
gone through so many people that sounds
like have you seen any like quick
indicators of the donkey like well how
do you how do you spot the donkey right
off we just talk to them and they'll
tell you and we love Millennials for
this reason the millennial generation is
a fabulous generation I get asked all
the time these leadership conferences
out of your iron Millennials buddy are
Millennials I love them they're awesome
because there's really only two kinds
awesome and sucks and that's the only
Millennials they don't and they don't
tell notice tell you I suck I live in my
mother's basement I don't intend to work
I got a participation trophy I'm not
doing squat I'll just tell you and good
we're not hiring you but the other ones
the ones that care and they join a cause
they'll storm the gates of Hell with a
water pistol man they're missional they
will fight they drive they believe
they're loyal it's the best generation
I've ever hired as an old leader I can
tell you it's a fabulous generation
what's your management style it hasn't
like in your office how do you there's
some people who are you know delegate
errs are some people who are micro
managers what's your management's down
what do you recommend in terms of men
well I wouldn't really have hired you if
I didn't need you to do something I
didn't want to do so its delegation but
I'm gonna require you do this stuff with
excellence and and with a spirit on it
that the customer loves the fact that
they came into contact with the Ramsey
organization and so it's a high level of
expectation a lot of more like a coach
you know I used to say coach is somebody
that loves you dearly but you're a
little bit afraid they'll go crazy at
any moment kill you you know that's
probably me yeah
that's in from Pattin where he because
it yells the soldier and he leaves and
his adjutant says to him and they don't
know when you're joking generally so
it's not important for them no it's only
important for me to know well I'm I mean
I'm not unkind I don't yell and scream
or anything like that it's not but but I
mean it's you're gonna do the stuff
because that's what we're all here for
and this this place is bigger than any
one of us and so you're going to get
your work done and and if you don't then
you know we'll set you free in Jesus
name there's stuff you can do I mean
this does seem to be the commonality
between all the good managers that I've
ever seen is that they do it's all about
hiring the right person and leaving them
alone that if you have to intervene with
the person too much then you're a bad
manager and you're a bad hire if you
have to if you have to be in their face
all the time and that's why when I look
at presidents you know I'm not gonna
name any names when you look at
presidents and they're constantly
shifting staff or they're micromanaging
or going over people's heads that's the
mark of a bad business to me is somebody
who has to have only closely held people
who can't delegate out to control freak
that and so but you can't if you
delegate without being able to trust
someone's competence and their integrity
you have that takes time
if you delegate without doing that then
you're just irresponsible and so and we
have made the mistake in business and in
government if we just hire someone who's
talented and they got a good resume then
we'll just turn them loose no no no no
no walk with you a little bit here make
sure you know how to do this stuff the
way we're doing it make sure you really
know how to do it that you're not just
got a good resume so forth so I'm gonna
trust your integrity in your competency
and the bigger the job and the more
money that's involved more customers
that are involved the more that's on the
line the longer that's gonna take so as
an advocate of the free market some of
the big questions that have come up
recently one one that's obviously
starting to take from center stage is
the is the question of technology and
the idea of a permanent underclass the
idea that there's going to be some sort
of IQ dichotomy where people who are
smart are going to be able to work and
get jobs and everybody else is going to
be replaced by technology do you see
that as a problem in the future or you
know you think the technology will be
more of an aid than a hindrance
technologies are both simultaneously in
all of our lives blessing and a curse
and we've got kids who screen time it's
blowing their brains up there's all
kinds of problems with their brains with
too much screen time
you know we all you know check our inbox
and have to keep it clean like we're OCD
or something guilty and so on you know
we and yet I can do more
my personal efficiency is way through
the roof compared to even 10 years ago
and and so um it really doesn't require
that much brain matter to take advantage
of technology most people turn on their
televisions and sign into Netflix most
of them are listening this podcast and
they're figuring out a way to do that at
all social strata and so you know case
in point the dollars that are flowing
into those things we can see that that's
happening so that there's enough brain
matter grey matter to take advantage of
technology but it's always a blessing
it's always a curse and you know I
always think about that you know the
story of the guys that used to bring ice
blocks and tongs on a wagon and set them
in a box called an ice box that was
basically a cooler and you're in your
kitchen it was not it didn't have any
refrigeration and then freon was
invented well the ice Tong guys went out
of business right well one of them had
an ice house in Dallas
Jerry gram and Jimmy Jimmy Graham they
called him Uncle Jimmy and he decided to
store bacon and milk and stuff in his
ice house and you could come by and pick
it up anytime between the hours of 7:00
and 11:00 and he started a little market
chain and so and the ice business today
by the way is a 5 billion dollar a year
business and nobody's got tongs so what
what does that mean it means we adapt
those that are gonna win there's market
disruptions welcome to life and they
come at you and they present either the
death of your business or the life of
your business be ready they're coming so
you've had a ton of callers obviously
over the years is there any one that
really sticks out to you as particularly
memorable or it's just at this point
kind of faded into the I've had several
of these but I guess the first time it
happened it sticks in you know sticks in
your memory she called me from San
Antonio and it was Monday and San
Antonio's big military town and her
husband special forces guy had been
killed in Afghanistan the day before and
she's calling me crying what'd I do
well we work with military folk a lot so
I knew all their programs and they do a
great job of coming around there they're
the spouses when they lose somebody so I
knew that they were going to be there
but we were able to plug her in with a
good church locally and one of our
coaches locally and one of our
investment advisors locally and we were
able to put all those people around her
to help her and walk with her because I
obviously in two minutes on the radio
how do you I just couldn't I just cried
with her I just torn me up I'm thinking
about right now but I can't imagine
getting that call those guys standing on
your front porch you know those get you
and but you know radios a blast there's
humans there man one guy called and said
my wife says she won't have sex with me
if I don't make at least $600 a month
what do you think about that Dave Ramsey
I think I'd get to work I want to ask
you about as I sort of referenced
vaguely earlier there's been this debate
that's broken out now on people among
people on the right and one side of the
debate people like me on the other side
people like Tucker Carlson we had Tucker
on the show you know probably a couple
of months ago at this point and Tucker
was going on about how America had left
the the non college educated man behind
how these people were basically stuck
there was no way to get them forward and
he actually said in a monologue on Fox
News that the market the free market is
just a tool that we shouldn't see it as
a system we should just see it as a tool
and just like any other tool we should
be able to play with it into what we
want with it and all the rest and when
he was sitting in that chair one of the
things that I said to him is it seems to
me that you've lost the sense of
American adventure Leahy because he said
you know that if why should it be that
if you grew up in a small town and your
grandparents are buried here and your
parents live here that you should have
to pick up and move if there are no jobs
in that town I said well because that is
the biblical injunction and has been the
nature of adventure-seeking people in
all of human history that was the
guarantee of America but it seems like
this is a mindset that setting in for a
lot of folks I was born here I should
stay here there's no reason for me to
leave you know do you see do you see
that as a trend as well well Turker not
started on fox business when it first
started together he
friend long time oh she's sitting here
socket in this ultimate person that's
just hogwash he needs to get out of
Manhattan more you know when you walk
around the real people out here some of
these little towns are dying and evil
Walmart took over the town or evil
whatever took over the town and ran the
little guy out of business again that's
a marketplace disruption this great old
book one at one in John Grisham's books
painted house it's fictional but the
story is about cotton family cotton
pickin family white trash lowering
lower-income white trash in Arkansas and
the cousin had enough picked up got in
the truck got a bus ticket went to
Detroit because they were hiring people
to build cars and he came back a year
later with a Yankee wife right and
driving a new car and he'd made more
money than the rest of the family put
together putting cars together for a
Henry Ford and so what'd he do there was
no economic things available so he
picked up he went to Detroit I mean when
the hurricane hit New Orleans you know
what happened we got Cajun restaurants
all over the United States the people
left and never went back they left
because their homes were destroyed their
businesses were destroyed but then they
got comfortable we got great Cajun
restaurants two of them are friends of
mine in Nashville that we're from New
Orleans and the whole reason they're
there was Katrina that's the reason
they're there so when economic calamity
or lack of opportunity is there you pick
your butt up and you move there's always
been a diaspora an economic diaspora
there has always been that there's
always movement you know to the state of
Florida you know because of the you know
the snowbirds all there's always a thing
and and taxation and policy drives that
there's people leaving the state of
California as if the place is on fire
right now going to Texas I mean the
whole the whole thing the whole
political makeup of Texas is shifting
because of California's movement moving
there to get away from the taxation and
the same thing coming out of Connecticut
and out and out of New York I mean you
got to make a lot of money extra to
offset the taxation so all of those
things play into and there's always been
a sense of you need to move I don't want
to move I like my town I'm comfortable
there but if it means feeding my family
if it means leaving my debt you know
my destiny that God's given me I'm gone
let's go when when it comes to the
question of sort of how to raise your
kids in this culture what sort of tips
do you have for young parents
particularly who are being hit with a
lot of cultural influences that suggest
precisely the opposite of exactly the
lessons you teach how do you shield your
kids cuz you brought up three great kids
of towns like how do you go about
protecting them from this and and
inculcating in them exactly the sort of
values you're talking about
well I the first thing is my friend Andy
Andrews says don't try to raise great
kids raise kids that are going to be
great adults and that's a different
thing because great kids are like little
Stepford children and they don't ever
embarrass you in the restaurant and
they're always perfect in all this BS
and they're never that way they'll poop
in their diaper right in the middle the
worst possible time and scream in the
middle of church you know that's kids
that's because they're kids that's what
they do but what we are going to teach
them to do is to have critical thinking
skills and I'm going to be a whole lot
more concerned with your character than
I am your GPA I'm gonna be a whole lot
more concern with the way you treat your
brother or your sister and the way you
talk to your mother in my house then I
am whether you did a piano recital and
so sometimes we we raise the activity
level all the activities we plug our
kids into as a substitute for teaching
them character and you know we just
taught them you can't lie it will hurt
you because I will hurt you so that you
don't get hurt later and you know well
you paddled your children you dadgum
right most of my best friends were
paddled as kids and you beat your
children you know I'm not a child abuser
I love my children more than anything I
take a bullet for him but they turned
out and part of that was you know the
nurturing of their mother the fear of
their father don't even talk about that
sort of stuff these days is obviously
very much I get hate mail for days I
will after this that's okay all right I
made a living off of it it's okay well I
mean this is this is the fun stuff that
we get to talk about all the time and
you talked about in your show too is
sort of the distinctions between male
and female roles in the household how do
you see that well I'm probably
middle-of-the-road my daughter called me
a feminist the other day I couldn't
believe it but I'm you know I talk
take feminism toxic masculinity has been
in the news this week obviously we don't
want to do any of that but as a husband
as a dad my job is to love my family to
serve them and take care of them and
that may mean the way I serve my
eight-year-old is I may make him brush
his teeth and maybe I mean the way I
serve my 16 year old is you don't get to
drive tonight cuz you're not been acting
right it may be and they don't feel
served when you're doing that but I'm
serving them I'm their dad I love them
more than anything on the planet and
that that's the way I view it is not my
goal is to serve but no I mean my wife
has been a full-time mom but if she
wanted to have a career I don't care my
mama's are working mom and that that's
fine I mean your wife's a working lady
and a lot of three of our operating
board members in our company are very
very sharp ladies and so and no issue
with that at all it's you know what do
you want to do with your life how do you
want to do it and how can we support
each other to win I don't make decisions
unilaterally at our house and neither
does my wife by the way so big decisions
we talk about it and we come together on
it and that includes talking about
something going on with the kids or a
large charity donation or gonna buy this
building to put our company in or you
know in the old days when we were hired
when we hire people we always interview
them with their spouses and with our
spouses because spouses see stuff and so
that you know we just work together it's
a team so you know a lot of the basic
values that you talk about it seems like
a lot of folks in the country
ideologically do not hold those values
and it seems like they are located in
particular states around the coasts do
you think that this is a gap that's
bridgeable because this is really a
concern for you know for me is is that
as I said that it's almost two separate
Americas it's a group of Americans who
take very seriously traditional values
and who still think that it's worthwhile
to go to church and inculcate those
values and their kids and then there's a
group of folks who seem to think that
those values our old fashioned outmoded
that we live in an experimental age in
which you basically ought to let your
kids run roughshod over you or do
whatever they want in which it's a
mistake to try and teach your kids
anything and in fact it's an act of
parental tyranny to try and teach your
kids anything do you think that that gap
is bridgeable or do you think it's going
to continue to sort of bifurcate
all weight probably comes and goes we
kind of went through that in the hippie
movement in the 70s we've gone through
it we went through a little bit with the
Gen Xers some of the quotes skateboard
crowd remember those guys and all that
kind of thing every generation has to
have to push back and has to pull but
yeah we're seeing some of the fabric of
our culture and Ravel some of those
values that are basic human things the
the loss of civility though in the last
36 months 48 months has just this
political correctness police you can't
say anything that someone doesn't like
anymore without them going absolutely
bananas I mean they'll destroy a
teenager's life whether it's all right
or the left I mean the young man has
stood up on the left from the school in
Florida that there was a shooting I mean
all right went after that kid and
basically just ate him alive he's like
he's a 17 year old boy
leave him alone people and then this
week the kids from Kentucky with the
Magna hats on with our mega hats from
baby we call it all that stuff but I
mean the one thing you need to
understand these cameras and audio you
can make people say almost anything you
want to say when they finish and I've
had it happen to me a time or two and in
print as well and so you can't believe
what you see on the Internet I know that
shocking the lack of civility to stop
and let's just stop a second and did
that pastor really do that and maybe did
I mean maybe he's a absolute reprobate
and he should be punished and he should
lose his standing for forty five years
of building that but did he actually do
that and so I think we got to just stop
a second and breathe before we just slit
everyone's throat on the first possible
offense oh my god were an offended
people it's ridiculous and II get extra
credit for being offended and you also
had an extra credit for being the first
person to go in for the throat slitting
because if it turns out that you got it
wrong well then you can sort of walk it
back a little maybe apologize maybe you
don't but if you get it right then yet
all sorts of credit as being the first
on the virtue signaling train exactly
exactly
and I'm in charge of virtue that's my
job for everyone else and turns out a
full-time job as a guy in my mirror
mm-hmm well in a second I want to get to
the final question for you here today
here yeah exactly so here's the question
the question is going to be on a scale
of one to ten one being entirely
risk-averse and ten being entirely risk
tolerant how do you rank yourself
because you're obviously an
entrepreneurial guy you're a guy who's
who's actually you know started a
massively successful business but you're
also somebody who says that you
shouldn't take out debt you should so
that seems risk-averse I'm gonna get the
answer from you in a second but if you
want to hear Dave Ramsey's answer you
have to be a daily water subscriber to
subscribe but go to daily where calm
click subscribe you can hear the end of
our conversation there well Dave Ramsey
it really is a pleasure to have you here
sir and it I can't express enough that
if folks haven't checked out mr.
Ramsey's stuff you haven't checked out
des stuff you really should he's helped
millions of people and including
apparently half the members of my family
so which I didn't even know is that Dave
Rams take so much for stopping thank you
sure
[Music]
avenge Shapiro shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Glover edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Dylan Kate's
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
title graphics by Cynthia and hula the
Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
[Music]